[Музика]
привіт усім, мене звуть Анна. Я
вчитель англійської мови, просто читаю - wahtah
Анна після того, як сьогодні приїде міс талантів,
ми продовжимо вивчати
стиль життя молоді, щоб підлітки мали
різний стиль життя, але перш за все,
які асоціації у вас виникають  я маю з
підлітками та підлітками спосіб життя та
підлітки живуть, тому мої
асоціації наступні, давайте подивимося на
дошку, їх майже немає -
отже перша асоціація, яка у мене виникла
з підлітками, це чому,
тому що зазвичай підлітки багато гуляють,
вони  спілкуватися зі своїми друзями і
ходити в різні місця, парки, фестивалі
і так далі наступні фестивалі,
так що, безумовно, наступною асоціацією
буде музика, є різні типи
музики, є різні стилі
музики, які підлітки слухають наступний
, як правило, коли ви  якщо ти підліток
близько 15-16 років, ти зазвичай
починаєш романтичні стосунки, тож підлітки знаходять
своїх хлопців і подруг.
хлопець або подруга інший
зв'язок з підлітками наступний
зазвичай підлітки не дуже
ладнають зі своїми батьками, тому вони
поводяться погано, тому я асоціюється з
поведінкою, у них можуть бути проблеми з поведінкою,
наприклад, або вони можуть поводитися
досить добре інший один підлітки
зазвичай дуже  емоційні, тому
вони виражають свої емоції по-
різному, тому інша асоціація, безперечно,
викликає емоції, що було б
для мене наступним. Це вечірки, тому підлітки ходять
на вечірки, які вони організують, або вони
ходять на вечірки своїх друзів, тому наступна
асоціація добре, тому коли вона  вечірка, на яку
ви зазвичай ходите до свого друга,
і ви там розважаєтеся, а потім
запитуєте батьків, телефонуєте батькам і
запитуєте їх, чи дозволять вони вам
провести вечір з друзями, щоб
ви влаштували піжамну вечірку, наприклад, щоб
ви  залишайся в будинку свого друга на
ніч, або це також називається переспати,
тому переспівай, коли залишишся зі
своїм другом на піжаму  наприклад, вечірка,
щоб ви проводили ніч
разом, і ви розважалися, дивлячись
фільми, їли попкорн, грали в настільні
ігри, добре,
які ще асоціації у нас
з підлітками, мабуть, найлегші з
них, які ми залишимо до
кінця  школа та коледж, тому школа, тому що
підлітки зазвичай ходять до школи та
коледжу, деякі з них насправді йдуть до
коледжу після того, як вони закінчать 9 клас,
наприклад, добре, так що це основні
асоціації з підлітками, які я
особисто відчуваю, а у вас
такі самі асоціації  це
добре подумайте, і інше питання, які
образи у мозку виникають, коли ви чуєте
про підлітків, тож які у вас
асоціації, мої тут, які у
вас, ви можете написати список із семи
до десяти асоціацій, які у вас виникають
із підлітками, давайте зараз
повернемося до теми
нашого попереднього уроку, давайте переглянемо
словниковий запас, який у нас був минулого разу, тому наше
завдання тепер полягає в тому, щоб назвати наступні
стилі на scr  На дошці ви
можете побачити картинки, і наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
нам потрібно спробувати згадати, як ми
називаємо ці стилі, щоб на першому
малюнку ми бачимо Беллу Хадід в
дуже простому платті, тож давайте згадаємо, як ми
називаємо це  дуже стильний, добре
, це нормкор. Ще одна картинка, яку ми
маємо тут, ви можете побачити дівчину в
джинсовій курткі і сукні з квітами
і капелюхом, і ця дівчина
трохи схожа на рок-зірку, тому
цей стиль називається м'яким гранжом  ще одне
зображення тут, ми бачимо дівчину з
пов'язкою, і вона має маску для губ,
яку вона, ймовірно, купила на якомусь
веб-сайті або, можливо, в магазині, і у неї
є якийсь щоденник, і насправді ця дівчина
представляла б стиль цілих дівчат
або цілих хлопців.  також
такі блогери, які знімають такі відео
чи пам'ятаєш, що таке цілі відео цілі
відео, це відео, як розпаковують те, що
ти купив, щоб вони йшли по магазинах, вони
купували цікаві речі, вони купували
одяг, вони купували косметику  тики, а потім
вони хизуються на відео, і вони публікують це
на YouTube, тому цілі дівчата, що їм це подобається
, добре, і останнє тут ми
бачимо дівчат, ймовірно, вони корейки,
і в Кореї є дуже популярний стиль поп-
музики, це  насправді досить
легко назвати це, так що це kpop корейська популярна
музика, шанувальники kpop холодні kpoppers
добре, давайте перейдемо до наступної частини,
тепер ми повинні зіставити назви стилів
з їхніми визначеннями, що іслам ні дитина
ні не заробив послугу, щоб жити
псевдонім with machinima, тому, перш за
все, давайте подивимося на лівий стовпець,
правий однойменний Патчетт Куна :
Халіфа багатство лабайк хвороба ми не можемо
мати дітей без насіння не так визначення,
як без джентльмена,
тому номер один kpop, щоб зупинити дівчат або зупинити
boys 3 soft brunch for seapunk 5 tumblr
girls 6 normcore 7 meme core 8 yucky ок,
я сподіваюся, що ви пам'ятаєте ці слова
з нашого попереднього уроку, тепер давайте порівняємо
їх з їхніми поясненнями та
визначеннями, щоб першими  t у
нас тут є слово kpop, отже, яке
визначення, на вашу думку, відповідало б цьому
слову, добре, бачите корейську поп-музику,
співаків називають айдолами, добре,
перегляньте визначення ще раз,
яке відповідає словам усі дівчата чи
цілі хлопці  дайте йому щось добре правильно
це H молоді люди, які купують речі та
магазини та знімають відео на YouTube, розповідаючи
всім, що вони щойно купили, наступне
слово, що ми маємо тут
м'який гранж ми щойно мали це слово
на картинці, як і два попередні,
тому  не повинно бути складно порівняти це
з визначенням, тому що таке м’який
гранж, це правильно, це
підлітки, які люблять фарбоване волосся, слухають
музику в стилі гранж і люблять носити стильні
футболки Nirvana, зазвичай добре,
четвертий бачить панка, тому якщо ми  Я
говорю про see Punk, це, безперечно,
те, що пов'язано з морем
з океаном, і насправді це
стиль одягу, це стиль одягу, який
складається з морських принтів, що є морським
це море,
добре, номер п'ять дівчата tumblr,
це дівчата, які використовують tumblr, це
спеціальний додаток із зображеннями, і ви можете
поділитися фотографіями свого способу життя,
тому насправді дівчата з tumblr - це дівчата,
які носять укорочені топи та шорти з високою талією,
вони люблять Starbucks і вони  люблю
сфотографував наступний нормальний суд,
ми щойно бачили фотографію Белли
Хадід у простій сукні, тому не
складе труднощів зіставити це слово з
визначенням, яке визначення ми маємо
використовувати тут, що таке ядро норми, що
ов'язано з буттям  нормально,
звичайно, правильно,
тому визначення, яке ми відповідаємо тут
, буде D акт деконструкції
моди або як знищення моди
навмисне одягання пустим або нудним і D
модні сукні добре наступне
передостаннє число сім основним мемом, щоб
ви пам’ятали, що таке  мем - це
зображення, яке визнають багато
людей, тому що було б ядром мему,
ймовірно, це використання цих зображень у
своєму одязі в тому, що ви хочете, так що так
, це  правильне визначення F цей стиль,
який використовує впізнавані зображення в
одязі,
який є основним мемом і номером вісім,
останнім тут, який прикольно. Пам'ятаймо
молодих творчих особистостей, про яких ми
говорили на нашому попередньому уроці,
добре, і у нас залишилося лише одне визначення,
тому це досить легко  Які —
молода людина, молода модна особа з вищого
середнього класу, тому Які — це ніби
новий хіпі, тепер ви
пам’ятаєте слова, давайте перейдемо до іншого завдання,
зараз ми читаємо статтю, і ви
можете сказати її назву на екрані
сьогодні  підлітки ростуть повільніше,
такий збудливий підліток, трохи літтке, ми
товстий старий венеціанец, тож це стаття, яку
ми зараз прочитаємо, подумайте про
ці слова, подумайте про назву, що
ми могли б прочитати про неї, але перед
цим подивіться на  слова нижче, ви повинні
про них подумати, і що ви
думаєте, що про ці слова скаже стаття,
що ви можете сказати про ці
слова у своєму житті та слова, які
вам потрібно  подумайте про таких
підлітків, які ростуть, поведінка, послуги,
відповідальність, ризикують,
бабусі та дідусі перше
побачення підробіток квартира соціальні мережі
реальний світ, тож як ці слова
пов’язані з заголовком статті, що, на
вашу думку, можна сказати про ці
слова, давайте подивимося  щодо деяких із них
обов'язків, ймовірно, стаття
розповість нам, що очікується від
підлітків, що вони повинні робити під час
навчання вдома і так далі,
поведінка, про яку ми вже згадували
на початку уроку, що
підлітки можуть мати певні
проблеми з поведінкою  проблеми, тож, ймовірно, ця стаття
розповість нам і про них, а
як щодо роботи на неповний робочий день, коли ви
підліток і, починаючи з 14 років, ви
можете почати працювати, коли вам виповниться
16, ви можете працювати ще більше, тому, ймовірно,
ця тема також  буде обговорюватися
в темі соціальні медіа, які сьогодні кожен
підліток використовує соціальні медіа, тому,
ймовірно, вплив
соціальних медіа на підлітка  Це буде
обговорено у статті, і реальний
світ не забувайте зв’язуватися з
реальним світом, не втрачайте зв’язок
із реальним світом, коли ви будете
підлітком, ймовірно, це може бути
краєм цієї статті, тому зараз, як  ми
передбачили, що ми могли б побачити і що ми
могли б прочитати в статті давайте насправді
прочитаємо це
стаття два дні підлітки ростуть
повільніше нове дослідження говорить, що сьогоднішні
підлітки ростуть повільніше,
ніж дослідження попередніх поколінь
Університету Сан-Дієго розглядало
дані  про поведінку підлітків за останні
40 років, між 1976 і 2016 роками, було
розглянуто опитування восьми мільйонів команд із
семи різних країн. Дослідник
сказав, що порівняно з підлітками
70-х, 80-х і 90-х сьогоднішнім підліткам потрібно
більше часу, щоб зайнятися задоволеннями
та обов’язками.  Професор дорослого життя
Джин Тренч сказала, що весь
шлях розвитку сповільнився, за
її словами, сьогоднішні 18-річні підлітки живуть
більше, як 15-річні раніше  У прямому ефірі вона
сказала, що підлітки ризикують набагато
менше, ніж до того, як дослідник сказав, що
сьогоднішнім підліткам потрібно більше часу, щоб робити
те, що робили їхні батьки, бабусі й дідусі
, коли вони старші, коли вони йдуть на своє
перше побачення, менше шансів мати роботу
неповний робочий день і
Професор Тренч рідше їздить за кермом, сказав, що це
повільна життєва стратегія. Дослідники також
виявили, що більше підлітків
довше живуть зі своїми батьками замість
того, щоб орендувати власну кімнату або квартиру.
Однією з причин такої поведінки
є те, скільки часу підлітки проводять
в Інтернеті.  продовжує підлітків у соціальних
мережах дивитися відео чи грати в ігри
замість того, щоб жити в реальному світі.
Іншою причиною були батьки, які намагаються
зробити занадто багато для своїх дітей і
захищають їх, тому тепер, коли ми
прочитали текст, ми розуміємо, що
підлітки сьогодні  ростуть
повільніше, ніж у попередні
роки, тепер давайте перевіримо ваше розуміння
тексту білий – це невідповідність Рам  навичка
Aikido brevis це мільйон fremitus текст
ми збираємося робити правдиву чи хибну
вправу подивіться на дошку
подивіться на екран білий епідерміс
Nikon oj nom nom, він знає Роберта,
ймовірно, захоплюється з
мачете nikkirech  у затвердженій жінці
правда в Джилліан Яблуко уряду
неправда з яскравими контактами Надаля для текстового повідомлення
до місії Великобританії звернулися до Аллаха, тому нам
потрібно вирішити, чи є речення
нижче правдивими чи хибними, ми маємо t для
істини, а F для хибності.  подивіться
на перше речення дослідники
переглянули дані про людей віком до 14 років чи
це правда чи неправда згідно з нашим
текстом, який був вік людей,
згаданих у тексті
, пам’ятаєте, ми говоримо про
підлітків чи можна говорити про  люди
до 40 років
точно не
говорили про підлітків, тому люди,
які жили в часи
70-80-90-х років минулого століття і
насправді вони порівнювали 40
років цих  народи, які живуть таким чином, це
неправда до 18 років, а не до 40,
дослідники номер два переглянули дані про 8
мільйонів підлітків, це правда чи неправда,
скільки підлітків вони досліджували
, ви пам'ятаєте, добре, так, це
безперечно вірно в тексті
згадав, що дослідники досліджували 8 мільйонів
підлітків
наступний номер 3 дослідники
порівняли сучасних підлітків з підлітками
1970-х років чи це правда чи це неправда чи ви
пам’ятаєте, що було згадано в тексті,
перевірте себе,
це правда підлітки 1970-х
років  порівняно з сьогоднішніми підлітками
також підлітки 80-х і
90-х, я сподіваюся, що ви пам’ятаєте, що
число сьогоднішніх 18-річних подібне до
15-річних у минулому, тож якщо ми
говоримо, що сьогоднішні підлітки
ростуть повільніше, ніж
підлітки попередніх поколінь те, що
було згадано в тексті про це,
ця інформація
вірна чи правда згідно з текстом, що
сьогодні, коли тобі 18 років ти
схожий на  15-річний підліток
з минулого, так, це справді істина
номер п'ять, дослідники сказали, що
підлітки більше не зустрічаються,
що насправді мають
дівчину чи хлопця, тож чи
правильно говорити, що підлітки більше
не зустрічаються сьогодні, ви пам'ятаєте  що
з тексту
добре, це неправда,
вони можуть просто почати це пізніше номер
шість, професор сказав, що сьогоднішні підлітки
мають повільну життєву стратегію добре ще
раз ми можемо використовувати нашу логіку і, звичайно,
речі, які ми пам'ятаємо зі
статті, і ми можемо припустити, що  так, це
була правда, що підлітки ведуть
повільну життєву стратегію, тому вони не
поспішають виростати до стратегії повільного життя,
о, хлопчики, ми будемо знати Хіджіту,
кілограмовий правець, окрім речі Раста, тому
це правда, згідно з текстом  добре
номер сьоме
проведення часу в мережі робить підлітків
більш відповідальними чи правда, чим більше
часу ви проводите в Інтернеті, тим більш
відповідальним ви стаєте чи правильно, що
ви пам'ятаєте з тексту  d у
тексті було зазначено, що ні, вони
не стають більш відповідальними,
підлітки не стають більш відповідальними,
якщо вони проводять занадто багато часу в соціальних
мережах та в Інтернеті загалом, а в останньому
реченні батьки, які захищають, роблять
підлітків більш відповідальними,
коли батьки приділяють занадто багато уваги  їхніх
дітей чи правильно, що дитина
стане відповідальнішою, я так не
думаю, а стаття і
дослідник професор каже, що це
неправда, добре тепер, коли ви перевірили
себе, перейдемо до наступного завдання тут у
нас є слова з  текст, який нам потрібно,
щоб зіставити їх із набором із
синонімами праворуч, тож давайте
подивимося на перший стовпець, де слова
з тексту та найгірше праворуч,
які є синонімами номер один,
попередні два дані три служби для
взаємодії  п'ять далеких шість, ймовірно, сім
стратегія вісім квартира
дев'ять причин десять захистити і тепер
слова праворуч, ймовірно, приєднатися до
побачити багато D причина II факти F план G
захист H раніше  I flat and J вивчає
зараз, коли ми переглянули
слова давайте зіставимо їх, тому перше з них
є попереднім українською, воно діє,
тому яке слово ми тут збігаємо правильно
ви це H раніше давайте перейдемо до номеру
два
дані фактично  синонім до
слова інформація, але у нас немає
слова інформація в стовпці праворуч,
тому яке слово могло б бути синонімом як до
даних, так і до інформації. Правильно,
це слово факти номер три служба
служби, як правило, анкета
так, коли люди  запитують про
щось їхню думку, а потім
факти,
дані збираються, то що це за
опитування, це дослідження типу
дослідження, але коли людей
запитують номер чотири,
що означає брати участь, це означає
приєднатися до бригади знати, що це
ми знаємо, що це слово
вживається у фразі далеко, як, наприклад, da
Lackey, далеко далеко в галактиці,
але тут воно трохи
інше, тож що це може означати h  перед тим, як воно
насправді посилює значення
одного, і це повільніше, але не
інше, що Кавазос ніч старший у романі Самос,
коли я сподіваюся, що це Ілля огія, лист
за об'єктом, дюйми довгий емоційний
Бухарест — це лава далеко, навіть ніхто не сказав, що
він не дуже блискучий  число шість ймовірно,
коли щось імовірно станеться, це
означає, що цілком імовірно, що це
станеться так ймовірно, є
синонімом слова ймовірно, наступна
стратегія – це те, чого ви
крок за кроком дотримуєтеся для досягнення мети, тому це
досить легко  зрозумійте, що
синонімом до цього слова буде план
наступна квартира номер вісім
квартира - це тип приміщення, в якому ви
живете, такий будинок з кімнатами, що
це не приватний будинок, а квартира
в багатоповерховому будинку номер  дев'ять
причин причина, чому ви щось робите
, так синонім до слова причина
буде причина Петріно, а номер
десять останнім, що потрібно захищати, - це
захистити добре добре дуже дуже добре дуже
добре робити  а тепер давайте перейдемо до іншої
вправи, яку ми маємо тут, давайте перевіримо,
що ви пам’ятаєте з тексту, це
будуть факти, згадані
в тексті, тож давайте подивимося на
перше запитання, чи пам’ятаєте ви, скільки
років
даних дослідники  подивіться добре
, це 40 років номер два, скільки
різних послуг переглянули дослідники,
їх було досить багато, ви
пам’ятаєте, і це було вісім мільйонів вісім
мільйонів людей, які були досліджені, номер
три дослідники порівнювали
сучасних підлітків з підлітками з
які покоління,
коли вони жили, коли вони були ці
люди підлітки були
підлітки в 70-х 80-х і 90-х номер
чотири,
які сьогодні 18-річні підлітки більше схожі на
те, що у нас щойно було подібне запитання в
попередній вправі з правдивими чи хибними
питаннями тут  ми повинні сказати, що
сьогоднішні 18-річні підлітки більше схожі на 15-
річних підлітків у минулому номері 5
які сьогоднішні підлітки беруть
менше або менше означає менше s  o не набагато не більше,
але менше, це було б ризиком, звичайно,
вони не ризикують так, як використаний
термін номер 6, яку роботу
сьогоднішні студенти рідше роблять,
коли ми говоримо про сучасних підлітків,
ми пам'ятаємо, що вони
вони можуть бути менш відповідальними, тому
вони не дуже люблять роботу, і вони насправді
не працюють на неповний робочий день № 7
Яку стратегію, за словами професора, мають
сьогоднішні студенти, то пам’ятайте, що
вони не поспішають дорослішати  не
так швидко, щоб це було б
названо повільною життєвою стратегією ок номер 8
що сьогоднішні студенти не так багато орендували
сьогодні місця, щоб жити правильно, і це
слово було б квартири чи квартири
як синонім і номер дев'ять
останнє тут, де  чи в статті говориться про те, що
в Agers не живуть, ну
, ви пам’ятаєте цю
інформацію, добре,
згідно з дослідженнями
згідно з дослідженнями, вони не живуть у реальному світі, оскільки вони
використовують занадто багато соціальних мереж і вони  Ви
живете в Інтернеті, а не в реальному світі,
і тепер настав час для заключної
частини нашого уроку, подивіться на
екран, тепер у вас є домашнє завдання
для наступного уроку,
перше завдання говорить, що вам потрібно
розшифрувати слова і  запишіть їх
у копію назад тут у вас є
фрази, які вони взяті з тексту,
а слова, які вам потрібно розшифрувати
, підкреслені Шивон Петрівна макарони
з книжкою, де ви мочилися травою оніксової
лави, щоб не виходити більше, тому у нас
є сім фраз  тут ви можете
переписати їх у свої підручники, а потім як
домашнє завдання, яке ви повинні розшифрувати,
ви повинні виправити ці слова. Другий
тест, який у вас є, це написати
статтю в газеті про наступний
етап цієї нової історії, що може статися
з підлітками в майбутньому, як ви
думаєте, напишіть коротку статтю про
підлітків, які ваші прогнози
[Музика]
добре, тепер я чую дзвінок, а
це означає, що наш урок закінчився
сьогодні дуже дякую за
увагу до наступної зустрічі
[Музика].